[Music]  Nikki Hilton Rothschild gives birth to  baby number two the Rothschild family  has a lot to be thankful for this  holiday season just days before  Christmas 34 year old Nikki welcomed her  and husband James second child feel like  it just gets better and better the proud  mom announced the exciting news on  Twitter Friday writing christmas came  early on December 20th James and I  welcomed a baby girl  Teddy Rothschild into the world filling  very blessed the couple also shares  one-year-old daughter Lily Grace who is  officially a big sister and this makes  Nikki sister paris hilton and aunt for  the second time the whole family is just  really there's such an amazing couple  I'm excited Congrats to the family on  their new addition  [Music]  you